all i'm telling you is people are going  to offend you and i so just because  somebody offends us are we going to go  straight to the castle jail let's put  these people in jail is that what we're  going to be doing because the justice  system that we have  at least you can come out of it and you  can go through pro probation and then  you're free and we let them go right but  in the council culture they don't let  you back you're permanently canceled  it's a form of public execution if you  think about it it's character  assassination it's not even defamation  of character it's character  assassination public execution what can  we do to get rid of this guy